[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well look at this
nice looking horse
all right and we'll get now with that
good looking horse picture how much
a quarter
where you've been all summer did you
know horses was higher
closer at all
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear the five
three doubles i've got
i know six fights six and a half years
no seven
six and a half can you hear the seven
twelve the seven
can you that seven six and a half and so
the gentleman over there come right over
there
you'll see him in the races this fall
all right
edna and john
have decided to give up their house
and move into a flat
a lot of them in there
all right right hand what did you get
for all those picture frames
what are you farm
the house is too much trouble now
they've lived here 40 years and raised a
daughter
seeing the place empty out isn't easy
edna keeps busy
[Music]
[Music]
john is also a bit restless
he feels unnecessary
and is glad when the phone rings
hello
i have a long distance
this is john cummings
how are you and the kids and all
just fine
if she's well i'll call her
edna
edna
martha's on the phone
dad
i just got your letter
i think that's awful
you mean about the option
it's so sudden
it had to be done
it's too much for it
besides
social security
just goes so far
but what are you going to do well we
found a nice little flat
nearby
very handy don't you want to come out
here near off somewhere
no
i just feel awful
now your mother's got all her friends
right here
and i can get to the track now and then
it's the way we want it
can we help you somehow
no
we've thought it all out but dad you
have to be careful of yourself
is it going on now
on the phone
[Music]
what's the matter
i don't feel so well
i better call the doctor
[Music]
within an hour
edna is on her way to the hospital
[Music]
[Music]
within 48 hours
she is getting passive exercises
john will be taught how to do it
[Music]
it seems she's had a slight stroke
but the doctor says it's not serious
a slight paralysis is already wearing
off
[Music]
ten days later
edna is home
in the new flat that they've taken
they're going right ahead with their
plans
[Music]
a week later she's on her feet
another week
and she will be doing housework
hello you remember how fast this boy was
well we put him right up here in our new
flat
[Music]
regularly she takes pills to prevent
further blood clots
[Music]
there now
you see now
right straight and forward that's the
girl
good
fine
[Music]
looks to me like you're doing okay isn't
your doc
certainly is a girl edna
in part thanks to him he put me through
my paces well i was a horse trainer over
here at the trap for 40 years
many a day i sat by a sick horse
shouldn't be able to do as much for my
own wife
that's what he thinks of me he thinks
he's going to enter me in the preakness
now
and i'm not
don't you bet on that
i know a good feeling when i see one
[Music]
prognosis
many more years of life
the aging live on the edge of a
precipice
balances of pressure
arteries
blood chemistry
are in delicate equilibrium
if the balance is maintained there can
be health and joy
the statistics tell us she may live
another 10 or 20 years
edna is ready for them
but are we ready for edna
suddenly there are millions and millions
of edna's
are our communities ready
a century ago we did not need to ask
that question
in those days the ranks of the old were
thinned by every illness
every epidemic
a stroke then was a sentence of doom
they would say lie still
lie still
don't move
soon the muscles atrophied
the processes of life slowed
at best could be a period of living
death
then death itself
[Music]
the old was scarce then
for the few that lived on there was a
place in the farmhome
between the old and the very young there
was often a special bond
but the rural way of life they knew was
changing
everywhere families were on the move
some to the frontier others to the city
here there was less room for the old and
less use
the factory assembly line was recruiting
the young
not the old
in cramped city quarters the grandparent
was less welcome
[Music]
more and more the old were being shunted
aside into arms houses in this way their
needs could more easily be forgotten by
the outside world
most didn't last long
but that too was changing
in medical laboratories another great
transition was in progress
one by one organisms that had brought
countless epidemics were being subdued
smallpox typhoid fever diphtheria they
began to lose their sting
life expectancy went up the old lived on
in ever-growing numbers
in 1900 in the united states there were
about 3 million people over 65 by 1920
almost 5 million
1949 million
for the old
was it a boon
in the 1930s the great depression
10 million unemployed
among the old widespread suffering
more and more they were pushed outside
the economy
but 1935 wrote a memorable turning point
we accepted at last a national
responsibility
a social security insurance plan based
on earnings began to provide retirement
benefits
through amendments almost all workers
were covered and benefits were provided
for their dependence and survivors
by 1964 monthly benefits were going to
three out of four people 65 were over
but meanwhile
the old continued to grow in numbers
aided by new medical advances
it was found that enforced bed rest so
long accepted as sound treatment held
its dangers
instead of lie still
the doctors more often said
get up
even among victims of stroke he brought
dramatic results prolonging active life
1960
17 million over 65.
[Music]
and so edna like millions of others is
on her feet
[Music]
active
doing her housework
she and john look forward to the
promised golden years
the crisis has even given them a new
camaraderie
fixing the flat is an adventure
recalling old times
[Music]
as she takes up the tasks of
housekeeping
[Music]
john celebrates the triumph
by awarding her
a blue ribbon
[Music]
now he feels he can safely take a few
hours off
visit his old haunts at the track
see his old friends
relive old days
[Music]
have a look at the horses
[Music]
there outside the park
he is hit by an auto
an hour later the news is told to edna
as carefully as possible
john was killed instantly
a long-distance call is made to notify
the daughter
meanwhile edna is taken to a nursing
home
future arrangements are uncertain
the events are a great strain on her
her body struggles to maintain its
delicate balances
statistically the outlook still is many
years of life
what sort of years will they be
very soon there'll be 20 million
americans over 65.
millions of them like edna left alone
are we ready
are our communities ready
have we looked closely at this problem
in 1961 there was an historic white
house conference on aging
it was followed by legislation to help
communities throughout the nation
develop health services for older people
the law was called the community health
services and facilities act of 1961.
by now many urgent needs were known
now the emphasis would be on services
in many communities the public health
service began to foster projects showing
how needs could be met
through existing resources or new ones
many approaches were used
in some communities improvement of
nursing homes to provide not only the
needed beds
but also facilities for recreation
occupational therapy rehabilitation
[Music]
[Music]
in another community
services for those not sick enough for
institutions but not well enough to care
for themselves
visits to the home by nurses therapists
[Music]
for those unable to cook
portable meals served in the home
in another community
special health services in housing
projects occupied by the aging
[Music]
in another community
a clinic for preventive checkups to
ensure early treatment
[Music]
in another
scheduled visits by a podiatrist to
senior centers
for the all-important care of the feet
the aim
keep them walking
[Music]
in another provision for psychological
health
to counteract emotional depression
in another community
an information and counseling service
a social worker helps old people and
their families to plan for their
particular needs
the aim
not just to treat sickness but maintain
well-being
all these varied services have proved
valuable and necessary
but though proved they're still few and
far
between are our communities ready
most surely they are not
we have learned what is needed
experiments and demonstrations have
shown the way
but relatively few communities in our
land are ready
if they were
we know how the story might go
so let us suppose that we were ready for
edna and continue her story
her daughter martha arrives
two days later
after the funeral
they start the journey to martha's home
[Music]
so
[Music]
here
in an urban flat
some readjustments will be necessary
financially the family will manage
martha supplements her husband's
earnings with part-time work
during the children's school hours
and edna now receives from social
security survivor benefits
but edna
depressed
and worn out
takes to her bed
how will she be cared for
a difficult period lies ahead
[Music]
for emergencies of this sort
the nearby hospital arranges a temporary
homemaker service
[Music]
so
[Music]
gradually edna becomes more active
a few weeks later she begins to cope for
herself
but supporting services still come from
the hospital
[Music]
a nurse visits once a day
the doctor once a week
after a time
they feel she's well enough to come by
herself to the aging center at the
hospital
[Music]
edna begins periodic visits
at first
hesitantly
she has her blood pressure checked
also her hearing and vision
such checkups prevent many an accident
at intervals she receives new pills to
prevent blood clots
a checkup precedes each allotment
[Music]
two by two and take a little walk go
home with you and all the way around
now element looks like an element go
right now left hannah make your star in
a gents in a center with a backup star
now slip the clutch left dollar man in a
potner ride with a right left grin and a
ride on a left go around the range
she gets interested in the center's
recreation program first as a spectator
later actively
it becomes a regular part of her week
in the occupational therapy room
she acquires new interests
[Music]
the regular visits to the aging center
become important to edna
[Music]
[Music]
she still has periods of deepest gloom
sometimes she sits silent for hours
hardly noticing others
[Music]
[Music]
martha patiently
keeps involving her mother
in household tasks
edna's activities
slowly grow
[Music]
at the hospital she discusses her
depressions with a psychologist
and begins group counseling sessions
i
think that i
felt better after i went on the porch
and got a little sunshine on thursday
martha set up a little card party for me
and
i had
an afternoon
of uh fun perhaps you would say
but it seems like a very great problem
to
talk to people
or perhaps by talking some here and we
can help you with some of your problems
mrs hardy how have you been getting
along
very well
the months pass
and one day comes
an important moment
the hospital referral center recommends
edna for a temporary volunteer job
she helps with a scholarship fundraising
drive
she's on duty two hours
at first she fears the responsibility
but in the end feels exhilarated
[Music]
she feels
she's won another blue ribbon
[Music]
that afternoon walking home with
martha's younger son
edna feels a glow of pride
gradually she is moving into the life of
a community
by 1970 there will be 25 million people
over 65 in the united states
of all people since the dawn of history
who have ever reached the age of 65
more than a quarter
will be living
will we be ready
when husband and wife survive together
they're determined in most cases to
maintain a small home of their own
when one survives this may not be
practical
though many continue to live alone as
long as their health permits
some find a place with relatives or
friends
sometimes other arrangements are needed
whatever plan is followed
the old have special health needs
those over 65 need medical help at least
three times as often as other people
in any year at least one in six is
hospitalized
but with the right attention at the
right time
many can stay on the side of well-being
and joy
we have the knowledge to fulfill the
promise
if we will use it
at 65 the average woman now has a life
expectancy of at least another 16 years
they can be years of harvest
this night
there can still be the special bond
between the old
[Music]
that's the way the money goes
for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you